Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue dans une nouvelle vidéo,
bienvenue dans une vidéo spéciale puisque c'est la FAQ, la foire aux
questions, donc en anglais Q&A.
spécial pour les 10 000 abonnés sur YouTube.
Donc, je vous ai demandé de me poser des questions et j'ai
une vingtaine de questions, quasiment 20 questions auxquelles je vais répondre
dans cette vidéo.
Mais avant de commencer, bien sûr, le script de la vidéo sera
disponible.
Sur Patreon gratuitement, il suffit de s'inscrire et après,
vous pouvez accéder gratuitement au script.
Et surtout, un gros merci pour toutes les personnes qui suivent la chaîne YouTube.
J'ai commencé à poster mes premières vidéos.
juin 2025 juin/juillet
2025 et donc maintenant, on a passé les 10 000 abonnés.
Ce n'est pas très rapide, mais en même temps, c'est une bonne progression,
je trouve.
Donc, je suis assez content et je vous remercie de me suivre
sur YouTube.
Donc, j'ai quelques questions que j'ai eues sur Instagram et sur YouTube.
J'ai divisé ça en trois catégories.
La première catégorie, c'est les questions personnelles, donc
sur ma vie personnelle.
La deuxième catégorie, c'est les questions générales.
En fait, il y a deux questions.
Je n'étais pas sûr de... comment les catégoriser.
Donc, ce sera les questions générales.
Et enfin, la dernière catégorie, c'est les questions sur l'apprentissage du français.
Désolée, je suis peut-être un peu malade, donc ma voix est peut-être
un peu bizarre, mais j'espère que ça ne vous dérangera pas.
Et donc, on est parti pour la première question.
comment tu t'appelles.
Je m'appelle Félix.
je vais avoir 32 ans la semaine prochaine
et donc je suis français et je suis professeur de français.
quel est ton endroit préféré en France?
Mon endroit préféré, c'est un peu difficile puisque la France,
c'est un très beau pays.
Je suis un peu chauvin, mais je pense sincèrement que la France est un très beau pays.
Ma région d'origine, c'est le Pays Basque, donc c'est le sud-ouest
de la France.
ce que j'ai vu.
Pour moi, c'est sûrement ma région préférée.
Alors, j'aime beaucoup Paris et je pense que Paris, c'est...
sûrement une des plus belles villes au monde, mais pour maintenant,
pour vivre le pays basque, c'est
une région plus calme et donc c'est plus agréable,
et c'est sûrement ma région préférée en France.
Mais après voilà, vous avez la Bretagne, vous avez le Sud-Est aussi qui est très beau,
vous avez la Corse, vous avez le centre aussi de la France,
enfin bref, il y a plein de choses à voir donc,
N'hésitez pas à visiter et je vais essayer
de visiter plus les régions françaises.
quelle est votre série préférée et pourquoi vous l'aimez.
non qui Je ne regarde pas beaucoup
de séries, enfin j'en regarde quelques-unes.
J'en ai pas forcément une en préféré mais j'en ai aimé quelques-unes.
Une que j'ai beaucoup aimé, c'est Dark, donc c'est une série allemande,
je crois.
En fait, ce que j'aime dans Dark, c'est que c'est…
c'est assez complexe.
En fait, il y a une intrigue au début de l'histoire qui est assez
complexe et on a un peu du mal à comprendre.
Et en fait, au bout d'un moment, tout commence à devenir...
On commence à tout comprendre en fait, c'est-à-dire que les choses qui sont complexes,
on commence à démêler les problèmes, c'est-à-dire on commence
à avoir un peu plus clair, à mieux organiser les problèmes.
Et j'aime ce genre d'histoire où au début on a du mal
à comprendre ce qui se passe et au fur et à mesure, tout se met un peu
dans l'ordre, tout devient un peu ... pas rationnel mais l'histoire,
on commence vraiment à comprendre l'histoire.
Désolé, en plus, je fais la FAQ vraiment sans script, donc c'est improvisé.
Mais j'aime bien ce genre d'histoire et par exemple, j'avais ressenti la
même chose avec la première saison de Westworld où c'est pareil,
au début, on a plusieurs histoires séparées les unes des autres.
On ne sait pas trop quelles sont les liens entre les différentes histoires
et à la fin de la première saison,
tout se reconnecte en fait.
C'est vraiment quelque chose que j'apprécie dans les scénarios.
Et sinon, après, j'ai beaucoup aimé, par exemple,"Mindhunter".
c'est une série policière, mais voilà.
En série... Ouais, c'est à peu près ça.
Comment avez-vous décidé de quitter un poste de business analyst
pour devenir professeur ?
Je ne veux pas dire que c'est un mauvais choix, mais j'étais curieux car j'ai l'impression
que le métier de business analyst est mieux rémunéré
et souvent considéré comme plus prestigieux, par exemple chez McKinsey.
C'est une très bonne question et ce n'est
pas– enfin– en effet,
c'est une question que je me suis posée au moment où j'ai voulu changer.
Est-ce que je prends une bonne décision parce que…
Avant, j'avais un travail... J'avais un CDI, donc en français on dit CDI
pour un contrat à durée indéterminée.
C'est le contrat le plus sécuritaire,
on est le plus en sécurité
avec ce genre de contrats parce que c'est difficile
pour l'entreprise de nous licencier.
Et donc, en France, avoir un CDI, c'est un peu le Saint-Gral
et surtout quand c'est un métier bien rémunéré et considéré comme prestigieux.
Comme tu l'as dit, c'est d'un point de vue extérieur, on peut se demander pourquoi.
Et en fait, c'est tout simplement parce que mon métier d'avant
de business analyste, je commençais à m'ennuyer, je commençais à
en avoir marre.
Je n'avais plus l'impression que ça avait vraiment du sens.
à part gagner de l'argent en fait.
La seule raison, en fait, à un moment,
je me suis posé la question"Qu'est-ce que j'ai envie de faire?"
et la seule raison qui me disait « je veux continuer à être business analyste ».
C'était juste de dire, je gagne beaucoup d'argent, enfin, beaucoup d'argent.
Je gagne un bon salaire.
Je n'étais pas riche, mais enfin, ça dépend, mais... disons
que j'avais une vie aisée à Paris.
Je pouvais vivre à Paris sans me restreindre, sans…
sans avoir à compter mon argent.
Et donc ça... À partir du
moment où j'ai compris que ma seule motivation c'était l'argent,
je me suis demandé, est-ce qu'il n'y a pas quelque chose d'autre qui me plairait,
même si je gagne moins d'argent?
Et professeur de français,
j'ai pris cette décision parce que j'adore toujours apprendre le japonais.
et je suis vraiment tombé amoureux de l'apprentissage des langues,
donc j'avais envie de faire quelque chose en lien avec ça.
Maintenant, pour l'instant, je ne regrette pas du tout.
Pour l'instant, je suis même très content d'avoir pris cette décision.
C'est difficile financièrement.
Donc, pour l'instant, je suis dans une phase où j'essaye de…
de gagner ma vie, de gagner un salaire correct pour pouvoir vivre et après,
dans le futur, on verra de toute façon si ça reste trop difficile ou si j'arrive à bien
développer mon travail, auquel cas peut-être qu'à un moment,
je gagnerai autant que dans mon travail précédent.
Pour ce qui est du prestige, c'est sûr que quand vous dites à quelqu'un,
je suis sales analyste chez McKinsey, les gens vont se dire « Ah,
c'est quelqu'un d'intelligent, etc.
», ce genre de choses, alors que quand je dis « Je suis professeur
de français, langue étrangère ».
peut-être que les personnes ont moins ce réflexe de se dire
que c'est quelqu'un d'intelligent.
Mais honnêtement, je pense que c'est plus superficiel et que
si, dans mon cas, à partir
du moment où j'ai su que je prenais la bonne décision…
tout cet aspect un peu de statut, de représentation, de prestige,
tout ça, ce n'était plus un problème.
Je pense que ça aurait été un problème si mon nouveau métier ne me plaisait pas en fait.
Mais ce n'est pas le cas.
Mais au moment de prendre la décision, je me posais beaucoup
de questions et j'avais un peu de stress parce que je n'étais pas
sûr que ça allait me plaire.
Il faut essayer pour savoir, mais c'est toujours un peu stressant.
racontez votre première rencontre avec votre femme s'il vous plaît,
j'adore vos vidéos au fait.
C'est assez simple, on s'est rencontré sur l'application Tinder.
Et au premier date, on était tous les deux pas mal stressés
parce qu'on est tous les deux assez introvertis, je pense,
donc aller à un date pour parler avec une personne sans connaître la personne,
ça peut être un peu stressant.
Et du coup, on a beaucoup bu d'alcool, on est allés dans un bar
et en une heure, une heure et demi à peu près, on a bu trois pintes de bière,
donc autant vous dire qu'après, on a marché dans Paris et
c'était assez folklorique.
Donc voilà, à peu près la première rencontre avec ma femme.
Ensuite, on a un commentaire de Ben.
Félicitations pour tes 10 000 abonnés.
Est-ce que c'est difficile de gérer le temps et... et le travail
sur ta chaîne YouTube quand tu as d'autres activités.
et d'autres obligations.
Tes vidéos en français à vitesse réduite sont très bien faites et très utiles
pour apprendre.
Merci Ben.
En gros, actuellement, mon temps se divise en plusieurs parties.
J'ai les cours de français qui est le
moyen avec lequel je gagne de l'argent actuellement.
Donc, c'est un peu ce qui est prioritaire parce que si je n'ai pas de cours,
je ne gagne pas d'argent et donc je ne peux pas continuer à vivre comme ça.
Donc, les cours de français, là maintenant,
je suis à environ 20-25 heures de cours par semaine.
Donc,
ça prend un peu de temps et ça prend un peu plus de temps aussi
à préparer les cours.
Et ensuite, j'ai tout ce qui est réseau sociaux, donc là, les vidéos YouTube.
Les réels Instagram et TikTok.
Et ça, ça dépend.
La vidéo YouTube, ça peut aller assez rapidement.
En fait, ce qu'il faut, c'est que j'ai une idée de vidéo et après,
quand je filme, Comme c'est de l'improvisation, comme ce n'est pas scripté,
j'allume la caméra et en fait je parle.
Donc, ça, c'est assez rapide, ça prend 25-30 minutes à filmer.
Et après, j'ai le montage vidéo, là, sur l'ordinateur, je fais le montage vidéo.
Et ça, peut-être que pour chaque vidéo, c'est peut-être une heure.
En sachant qu'en fait, il n'y a pas vraiment de montage vidéo
pour ce que je fais, mais ce qui prend du temps, c'est de créer les sous-titres
et de les corriger.
J'ai un outil qui crée automatiquement les sous-titres.
Et ensuite,
je re-regarde la vidéo pour essayer de corriger du mieux possible les sous-titres.
Et enfin, je mets ça en ligne, je mets ça sur
YouTube, sur les plateformes de podcast,
sur Patreon, etc.
Donc je pense qu'en tout, oui, ça doit me prendre environ une heure
pour tout faire après avoir filmé.
Donc en tout, une vidéo YouTube, on va dire une heure et demi,
deux heures pour faire une vidéo.
Pour ce qui est des réels, des shorts sur Instagram et TikTok,
c'est plus rapide, mais comme j'essaie d'en faire tous les jours,
ça demande un peu plus de temps.
En général, j'essaye une fois par semaine de prendre une ou deux heures.
pour faire 7 petites vidéos, comme ça, c'est fait.
Et enfin, il y a le projet secret.
Le projet secret, c'est juste une plateforme pour apprendre
le français.
Et donc ça, j'essaye de consacrer du temps.
parce que... J'ai envie
de développer ça, j'ai envie de sortir une plateforme
où les gens peuvent s'inscrire,
s'abonner pour avoir à disposition des cours de français,
on va dire, classiques et aussi du contenu adapté à chaque niveau.
Et ça, ça prend beaucoup de temps puisque je dois créer déjà toutes les vidéos
de leçons, de grammaire, etc.
Je suis en train d'écrire tous les scripts, je vais devoir créer toutes les vidéos.
Ça, ça prend beaucoup de temps, mais du coup, c'est ce que j'essaye
de faire en dernier.
C'est le moins prioritaire, mais c'est quand même important.
Donc voilà à peu près comment je divise mon temps.
mon travail.
Qu'est-ce que tu as fait pendant une année sabbatique?
Est-ce que tu le ferais encore une fois?
Et comment les personnes ont réagi à ça?
J'ai pris une année sabbatique, enfin, on a pris une année sabbatique
avec ma femme.
On a pris une année de pause pour partir un an au Japon.
On est allé au Japon,
on avait économisé de l'argent donc au Japon on n'a pas vraiment travaillé,
on a voyagé mais on a aussi fait du woofing donc on a travaillé
dans des fermes et en échange on n'est pas vraiment payé mais on est logé
et nourri donc on habite avec les personnes,
on habitait avec des familles japonaises et la journée on travaillait
avec elles dans les fermes.
Si c'était à refaire, je referai exactement la même chose.
Je ne changerai rien du tout.
Je referai à 100% la même année.
C'était extraordinaire et pour rien au monde, je ne changerai cette année.
Maintenant, comment les personnes ont réagi à ça?
Donc peut-être que tu penses à nos familles, etc.
En Europe, c'est assez commun de faire une année sabbatique
pour partir à l'étranger et faire une expérience.
Et je pense que ça n'a pas du tout posé problème parce que...
On travaillait déjà, on avait économisé de l'argent et ça faisait
plusieurs années qu'on parlait de ce projet.
Donc finalement,
les gens n'étaient pas vraiment surpris et comme on avait bien préparé cette année
de pause, tout le monde était plutôt…
Tout le monde trouvait ça bien en fait, tout le monde nous encourageait.
À la limite,
je pense que ça a été un peu plus difficile
quand on a dit qu'on voulait changer tous les deux de métier,
ma femme et moi, qu'on voulait recommencer un nouveau travail.
Là, ça pose plus de questions, par exemple.
Mais voilà, sinon cette année, je referai exactement la même année.
Et... Et je suis super content d'avoir fait ça.
Félicitations, quel est ton meilleur souvenir dans la vie?
jusqu'à maintenant.
Donc, c'est difficile à dire, je ne sais pas
vraiment... Mon meilleur souvenir,
bien évidemment, ça pourrait être d'avoir rencontré ma femme
ou ça pourrait être d'être allé un an au Japon.
Cette année au Japon, c'était, je pense, un de nos meilleurs souvenirs
avec ma femme.
Donc, c'est un peu difficile d'en choisir un.
Mais si je devais choisir un, je pense que je choisirais l'année au Japon.
C'était avec ma femme.
On a passé une année extraordinaire et je rêverai de recommencer.
Qu'est-ce que tu aimes le plus dans le fait d'aider les autres à apprendre le français?
C'est une bonne question, en fait, je pense que j'ai toujours aimé expliquer des choses.
pour commencer et ensuite
quand j'ai commencé à apprendre le japonais en fait j'ai découvert un peu
Pas une nouvelle méthode, mais j'ai découvert une nouvelle vision
de l'apprentissage des langues et j'ai beaucoup aimé.
À l'école, je n'étais pas très doué pour apprendre les langues.
et j'ai passé... j'ai passé...
et j'ai passé 7 ans à apprendre l'espagnol et j'étais vraiment super mauvais.
Et donc, au moment où je me suis dit je vais commencer à apprendre le japonais,
j'avais plutôt en tête que j'étais mauvais dans l'apprentissage des langues.
Et en fait, en commençant à apprendre, j'ai découvert un peu des...
pas des méthodes,
c'est pas une méthode secrète, mais un peu une autre vision
de l'apprentissage des langues.
De travailler un peu tous les jours et de faire de l'immersion.
Essayer d'apprendre avec plaisir et sans forcément que ce soit trop théorique,
etc.
Et ça, à partir du moment où j'ai trouvé ça, je me suis dit mais en fait,
j'ai envie de partager ça avec d'autres personnes.
C'est un peu comme quand on découvre quelque chose et qu'on a envie
de le partager.
Je trouvais ça très intéressant d'essayer de faire ça comme travail.
C'est d'autant plus intéressant que je trouve que c'est difficile.
C'est difficile parce que... On ne peut pas juste dire aux personnes.
travaillez tous les jours, regardez des vidéos et vous allez apprendre le français.
Idéalement, c'est ça la phrase, enfin, c'est ça que j'ai envie
de transmettre, mais c'est plus difficile de donner envie aux gens
de faire ça.
Et ça, je trouve ça super intéressant.
À côté, il y a aussi tout l'aspect biologique,
c'est-à-dire pourquoi est-ce qu'on mémorise certaines choses,
pourquoi pas d'autres.
Qu'est-ce que c'est une langue?
Comment fonctionne une langue?
Qu'est-ce qu'on doit apprendre pour connaître une langue?
En fait,
c'est un sujet où il y a énormément
de questions et c'est très difficile d'avoir la réponse parfaite hyper précise et qui
reste simple.
Donc voilà, je pense que c'est intéressant pour... pour tout ça.
Et je pense que j'aime... enseigner le français à d'autres personnes
grâce à ces questions, enfin à cause de ...
grâce à ces questions.
Est-ce que tu prévois de venir au Japon?
j'adorerais venir au Japon.
Avec ma femme, on adorerait venir au Japon.
Cette année, ça va être un peu compliqué parce que financièrement,
c'est un peu compliqué.
Mais l'année prochaine, on va y aller.
On a beaucoup d'amis à voir.
On a même des amis qui ont eu un enfant.
Donc, je pense qu'on va essayer d'y aller au moins 3 semaines,
voire un mois, l'année prochaine.
Le problème, bien évidemment, c'est que les billets d'avion sont...
sont chers.
C'est très cher.
Donc, il faut qu'on économise de l'argent et pour l'instant,
on ne peut pas vraiment économiser de l'argent.
Donc, à voir l'année prochaine.
On passe aux questions générales.
Quel genre de travail un étudiant peut trouver
en France en tant qu'étudiant étranger?
un travail où il n'a pas besoin de... de parler avec des clients en français.
Ça, honnêtement, je ne sais pas trop.
Déjà, ça dépend de votre nationalité.
Je pense que si vous avez un bon niveau d'anglais,
Peut-être qu'il y a des travails où
vous pouvez postuler comme personne qui parle anglais.
Et après, si vous êtes par exemple
asiatique, à Paris, il y a un quartier japonais,
il y a un quartier chinois, etc.
Donc s'il y a, par exemple, j'ai un étudiant japonais qui travaille
dans un restaurant japonais, là ça ne pose pas de problème,
on lui demande plutôt d'être japonais que d'être français.
La condition, c'est de parler japonais.
Donc peut-être
que vous pouvez trouver ce genre de travail où votre
langue maternelle est un avantage.
Sinon, après, ben... Vous allez
avoir peut-être les petits jobs classiques
chez McDonald ou ce genre de trucs.
Mais honnêtement, je ne suis pas certain, je n'ai jamais eu à faire ça.
Désolé pour la réponse qui n'est pas très complète.
Pourquoi pas faire des vlogs en se baladant et en parlant de ce
que l'on voit?
C'est une très bonne question donc blog, je pense, vlog, faire des vlogs
en se baladant et en parlant de ce qu'on voit, c'est une très bonne question et en fait,
je pense faire ça à partir du moment où je vais créer du contenu
pour les personnes vraiment débutantes.
Je pense que les personnes qui regardent ces vidéos ont un niveau suffisamment avancé.
pour seulement écouter une
voix.... disons que quand on est dehors
et que je filme ce que je fais, ça va être plus limité,
ça va être un vocabulaire plus limité, mais forcément, c'est plus facile à comprendre
parce que je montre des choses.
Aussi, ça demande plus de travail, donc par exemple, j'avais fait un vlog
sur une convention à Bruxelles
avec ma femme et ça avait demandé plus
de travail pour finalement que ça ne fasse pas beaucoup de vue.
Donc, pour l'instant, je privilégie les podcasts face cam.
Ce qui a de plus intéressant pour pratiquer vraiment et ça me permet d'en faire
plus souvent.
Et après, quand je vais faire des vidéos plus destinées aux
personnes débutantes, là je reprendrai
ce genre de vlog où je montre ce que je fais
dans la vie de tous les jours.
Et enfin, on passe aux questions sur l'apprentissage du français.
Est-ce que tu fais des cours individuels, sinon est-ce que tu en penseras?
Est-ce que tu penseras en faire?
Oui, je fais des cours individuels, donc vous avez tous les liens
dans la description.
C'est des cours de 50 minutes ou de 25 minutes, de 34 dollars
ou de 17 dollars, donc 34 dollars pour 50 minutes.
Je sais que c'est assez cher, donc si vous n'avez pas les moyens,
je suis désolé, mais c'est le seul moyen pour moi aujourd'hui
de gagner ma vie.
Donc, pour l'instant, je fais ce genre de cours.
Et après, avec la plateforme que j'ai envie de faire, ça serait plus accessible,
bien Évidemment, ça serait moins personnalisé, mais ça permettrait d'avoir...
d'avoir quelque chose de plus accessible.
Si les cours individuels vous intéressent, vous avez les liens
dans la description.
J'ai une question, en fait, quand je pratique l'oral, je répète les mots plusieurs fois.
Comment je peux régler ce problème et merci beaucoup.
Donc, ça, c'est un problème que j'ai aussi en japonais.
Et ce que j'ai commencé à faire, déjà, pour commencer, c'est d'écrire.
J'écris parce que quand on écrit, on a le temps de réfléchir aux phrases qu'on fait.
Quand on parle, on a un peu le stress de devoir dire des phrases tout de suite et du coup,
on a tendance à utiliser les mots qui reviennent le plus régulièrement.
Donc quand vous écrivez, vous avez le temps de choisir les mots
et pourquoi pas de choisir d'autres mots que ceux que vous utilisez beaucoup.
Ensuite, quand vous avez l'impression d'avoir un mot que vous utilisez beaucoup,
vous pouvez le noter et vous pouvez essayer de trouver un synonyme.
vous demandez à ChatGPT, par exemple, est-ce qu'il y a d'autres mots,
quel autre mot je peux utiliser à la place de ce mot?
Il va vous donner des options.
Et après, ce que vous faites, c'est que vous notez tous ces mots.
Et quand vous écrivez, vous avez cette liste de mots à utiliser.
Comme ça,
vous allez apprendre à les utiliser à la place des mots que vous répétez souvent.
Ça, je pense que c'est une bonne pratique pour commencer à utiliser
de nouveaux mots.
Est-ce que tu peux faire une vidéo qui parle des accents français?
peut-être avec des exemples parlés.
C'est une très bonne idée et je pense faire ça.
Je pense essayer de sélectionner des vidéos d'autres personnes qui parlent
parce que si je commence à essayer d'imiter les accents, ça peut être un peu bizarre,
mais c'est une très bonne idée de vidéo et je vais y réfléchir
pour une prochaine fois.
Quelle est la meilleure méthode pour apprendre des mots du vocabulaire
de manière rapide et efficace?
Ça,
c'est un peu la question à un million de dollars puisque c'est une des choses les plus importantes
dans l'apprentissage des langues.
Pour moi, ça se résume comme ça.
Il faut apprendre dans le contexte.
Il faut faire beaucoup d'immersion parce qu'avec la répétition,
vous allez mémoriser les mots, c'est-à-dire que si vous voyez un mot dans
une vidéo...
vous n'êtes pas sûr du sens et que vous le revoyez dans une autre vidéo,
votre cerveau va commencer à reconnaître de plus en plus le mot
que vous essayez d'apprendre et c'est très utile
pour pour mémoriser.
Ensuite, personnellement, j'utilise un système de flashcard
qui organise un peu les révisions pour le vocabulaire et je trouve ça très utile.
Vous avez un logiciel comme Anki par exemple.
Et enfin,
quand vous avez vraiment un mot pour lequel vous avez du mal à mémoriser le sens,
Là, je vous recommande des moyens mémo-techniques.
Donc, inventer une petite histoire pour le mot pour essayer
de le retenir.
Je donne toujours l'exemple du poulet parce que c'est un exemple auquel j'avais pensé,
mais ça peut être aussi par exemple jeudi,
donc j'avais un étudiant qui avait du mal à retenir jeudi pour Thursday,
et je lui ai dit,
imagine que Yoda dit à Luke Skywalker
que tous les Jedi s'entraînent le jeudi.
et ça serait comme quelque chose comme"All Jedis are training on Thursday". Et donc
dans cette phrase, vous avez"Jedi qui ressemble à jeudi" et"On Thursday". Donc ça lie,
c'est une petite histoire bizarre mais qui lie les deux informations entre elles.
Ça crée une connexion et ça, ça permet de mieux mémoriser,
de... ça permet de coller un peu l'information dans notre cerveau.
Quels sont tes meilleurs app, sites, movies?
film et série.
que tu recommandes.
sont tes meilleures recommandations pour en application, site,
film et série.
Donc moi pour les applications j'utilise Migaku, c'est un outil de flashcard qui permet
de créer des cartes automatiquement à partir
de vidéos YouTube
ou de... sur Netflix, etc.
C'est la seule app que
j'utilise, donc je n'utilise pas vraiment d'autres applications.
Ma recommandation, c'est plutôt de sélectionner une application
de flash card, notamment Anki par exemple, et d'utiliser
seulement une application.
Pas besoin de plus.
Pour les sites, le meilleur site qui existe, c'est YouTube.
Honnêtement, sur YouTube, vous avez tout.
Il y a tout à disposition et c'est une mine d'or pour apprendre des langues.
Donc vraiment, moi, je vous recommande d'essayer d'apprendre le maximum
sur YouTube.
sur les autres réseaux sociaux je trouve que c'est moins efficace donc privilégiez
YouTube.
Pour les films et séries, les films, les séries, c'est les séries très connues,
je ne connais pas beaucoup d'autres séries mais vous avez Lupin,
10% (Call my agent) et les films, vous avez des films comme"Intouchables","Amélie Poulain", etc.
Mais comme c'est des contenus natifs, c'est tout de suite plus
difficile à comprendre.
Est-ce qu'apprendre le français avec des dessins animés, c'
est efficace, même si ça manque de sujets plus adultes, on va dire,
de sujets plus matures?
c'est efficace si tu apprends des choses.
C'est efficace si tu…
aimes regarder des dessins animés en français et si tu apprends du vocabulaire.
Si tu aimes regarder, tu vas vouloir continuer de regarder et donc ça va être efficace.
Et si tu apprends de nouvelles choses, c'est efficace.
Bien évidemment, si tu regardes des choses qui sont trop faciles,
ce n'est plus vraiment efficace.
Mais…
Tant que tu peux apprendre des choses,
ça veut dire que c'est efficace pour ton apprentissage.
Et tu peux regarder des dessins animés, et après tu regarderas autre chose
sur des thèmes "plus matûres" entre guillemets ou des thèmes d'autres thèmes.
Mais en tout cas, la première question à te poser,
c'est est-ce que tu aimes ce que tu fais, est-ce que tu aimes ce que tu es
en train de faire et est-ce que tu as apprends des choses?
Si tu réponds oui à ces deux questions, c'est une bonne façon d'apprendre.
Donc, si tu aimes regarder ces dessins animés et si tu es à prendre du vocabulaire,
alors continue.
Quel point de grammaire?
est rarement utilisé quand on parle français.
Donc il y en a plein, bien évidemment, il y en a plein.
Mais une chose que je trouve, qu'on trouve très régulièrement
dans les livres de français, de grammaire
française, c'est l'inversion-sujet-verbe,
les questions qui inversent le sujet et le verbe.
Et ça, quand on parle, on ne l'utilise quasiment jamais.
On l'utilise seulement quand on parle de manière très polie. Et par exemple,
si j'appelle quelqu'un au téléphone ou si j'appelle... je sais pas,
un restaurant ou quelque chose comme ça.
Je vais utiliser ce genre
de...... formes très polies, mais c'est tout.
Et donc, souvent dans les livres, pour débutants.
On voit ce genre de questions, sujets verbes inversés.
Et pourtant, on ne l'utilise quasiment jamais quand on parle.
Donc, moi, pour ça, ma recommandation,
c'est plutôt de comprendre comment ça fonctionne et d'être capable
de reconnaître, mais de ne pas essayer de pratiquer.
Ça ne sert à rien parce que vous n'allez quasiment jamais
l'utiliser au début.
Le moment où vous allez apprendre à l'utiliser, vous aurez un niveau
avancé.
J'ai un étudiant par exemple qui apprend le français et qui prend des cours
pour passer le TEF, le TEF au Canada, mais il a un niveau très avancé
et du coup, lui, il doit pratiquer ce niveau très poli.
Mais si vous êtes en France, que vous débutez en français,
vous n'avez pas besoin de ça.
Si quelqu'un qui apprend le français et me parle d'une manière très polie,
je vais me dire"oula, cette personne est très forte et elle maîtrise différents
niveaux de langage". Donc voilà, ça c'est typiquement le genre
de sujet, de points de grammaire qui n'est pas utilisé.
Mais toute façon, quand vous regardez ce genre de vidéo, vous voyez un peu mon niveau
de... de Français quand je parle et il y a sûrement des points
de grammaire que je n'utilise pas.
Et ça, quand vous apprenez la grammaire, après quand vous faites de l'immersion,
ça filtre un peu.
C'est-à-dire que si vous apprenez quelque chose mais que vous ne le voyez jamais
dans une vidéo, vous allez petit à petit un peu l'oublier,
et avec l'immersion, vous allez continuer d'apprendre ce qui est le plus fréquent.
Donc c'est pour ça que l'immersion, c'est important, c'est
que ça filtre un peu les informations selon leur fréquence.
Et donc voilà, je vais arrêter la vidéo parce que ça fait déjà 34 minutes,
c'était une longue FAQ.
Merci pour toutes vos questions, pardon.
Merci pour les 10 000 abonnés
sur Youtube et la prochaine fois peut-être qu'on fera ça
pour les
100 000, on verra.
Mais en tout cas, j'espère que ça vous aura plu,
n'hésitez pas si vous avez toujours des questions, vous pouvez me les poser
n'importe quand et de toute façon je réponds aux commentaires.
Et voilà, s'il y a beaucoup de questions, on refera une FAQ,
mais bon, là c'était assez spécial.
Merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout et je vous dis à la prochaine.